Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie. This is going
to be my Arrow Episode 3 video. Lot of OG
Team Arrow stuff happening. So let's get into
it, careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet. And real quick reminder to
there's a new round of the reverse flash ring
giveaway this week all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video. starting with top five WTF Diggle
versus Oliver, so they they finally lay this
beast to rest nothing is more unpleasant than
watching your main characters fight it out
like you want them to be a team you want them
to have fun and beat the crap out of villains
so they finally make nice Diggle comes clean
about hive to been two years we have more
in common than you think Diggle it wasn't
clear a lot of the reason the Diggle has been
acting this way is because it's eating them
up inside that he has been unable to make
any headway in solving his brother's murder
he feels like he's been completely failing
this so that just that gets lumped in with
all the stuff that happened to Lyla last year
so the reason he's been so pistol off it all
over is mostly because his pistol off it himself
that's all good now let's all have a drink
og team arrow Felicity was on point this
week especially with the OG team arrow stuff
I mean I mean she was great and all her scenes
but it is I love the way they open the episode
original gangsta what a coincidence that she
ended up using a submachine gun later in the
episode on the number for OG Felicity is final
boss form Felicity best recognize there's
a lot of reasons why the Felicity character
is so much more fun the season you just the
way the writing heard the kind of arcs are
giving her like boss mode Felicity much more
fun than assistant Felicity she does get kind
of bossy pants in the episode but that's only
to slap Diggle and Oliver to their senses
which is just like get a hold of yourselves
figures should out your messing everything
up they kinda need that like all of her can
be relisted on his own integrals being really
really stubborn who else noticed like all
the little things that Felicity said that
she thought that she might be doing at some
point in her life pushes like at one point
I thought my might be a dental hygienist or
a molecular biologist she just like an expert
in almost everything Mr. Terrific is probably
an expert at all the things that she's not
an expert at you to remember that even though
they changed Mr Terrific a little bit from
the comics just the way the characters portrayed
a lot of the creative energy is still there
is still one of the smartest people on the
planet but for the most part his role in team
arrow will be as an inventor like coming up
with new technology the way Cisco does Cisco's
more of an engineer though he's better at
building stuff is what I'm really hoping to
see is Cisco help Mr. Terrific build his T-spheres better like Mr. Terrific develops the
technology Cisco is the character you would
go to to actually put it together and make
it work right on the number three though Mr.
Terrific knows Felicity's secret now but not
Oliver's what Felicity meant by that is that
Mr. Terrific knows that Felicity works with
the arrow but he doesn't know that all of
her is the green arrow although in Army he'll
probably find out at some point this season
it wouldn't be a new season of the show if
people didn't learn all of her's identity
the same things going to happen with Barry
and Patty spend it on the flash pretty soon
to first things first though they have to
say the company pretty clearly these tease
fears are gonna have something to do with
that the T-spheres in the comics can do
all kinds of stuff all they're doing right
now though is blowing up the spontaneously
exploding so they just this the show's way
of telling you that the T-spheres won't
be a thing for a couple more episodes if there's
anything that I don't think that the let them
do on the TV show just set of practicalities
sake it would be using the T-spheres to
fly like Mr Terrific can actually stand on
them and he uses them to fly around I'm not
expecting the show to do that in in terms
of costumes like Mr Terrific taking on his
comic book persona I think he'll look mostly
like this but for the rest of the season maybe
in the future season if he still on season
five or six then he'll get some sort of costume
to think about how long it took Diggle to
get that suit I would put tease fear completion
somewhere around wherever this project Genesis
stuff is going on with Damien Darhk they name
dropped phase 3 now obviously we have no idea
what that means we have no idea what their
timeline is that I would venture to guess
it has something to do with the midseason
finale it's all culminating toward some big
point when the rest of hive rolls into town
and she gets real be which on a number two
Damien Darhk's grand plan so he demonstrates
his abilities again and it looks like a form
of tactical nieces but he calls that a parlor
trick in that conversation they also call
out to project Genesis so because he's heavily
involved in mysticism I'm wondering if what
he's doing has something to do with raising
demons are you know something with the spiritual
plane Constantine is coming on an episode
five though he is mostly going to be involved
with Sara storyline fixing her so I don't
know how involved he's going to get with the
Damien Darhk storyline they can do one of
those things where he continues to help them
from off-camera when we do get to that Constantine
episode in a couple weeks just listen for
any references to what might be going on with
Damien Darhk and finally on my number one
WTF moment they resurrects there in the Lazarus
pit Nyssa tanks it and Thea and consequently
Sara are both going to have to kill people
to quiet the souls inside of them so first
things first they brought Sara back this is
really big deal I actually wasn't expecting
to have this scene till the Constantine episode
but the way this played out I think that the
kind of explain things so Sara's just go crazy
until Constantine helps quiet the souls inside
of her or maybe the explanation is is that
she doesn't even have a soul right now in
Constantine has to find it either way Sara's
completely crazy pants she is like what Thea
will turn into eventually I think that's the
idea I like deal will eventually evolve into
what's there is like right here so Constantine
will come help fix Sara I think the is solution
will take a little bit longer I think that
will be more of an internal battle that she'll
have to deal with some of you did ask me though
about racial goal like the racial cool that
all of her killed last year still being alive
because Merlyn says that the ad needs to kill
the person who wronged her instant she thinks
he's already dead merlins like what you just
have to keep killing people that's that's
the only way to keep from going completely
crazy but here's the big question if you have
to kill the person who wronged you does that
mean that Sara is going to have to kill Thea
obviously I don't think that the is going
to die really is gonna be a should storm between
the three of them between Merlyn Sara and
Thea until Constantine arrives then you to
think about what's going on with Nyssa she
wants to get rid of macro Merlyn she completely
hate them especially since he aided in bringing
back Sara so she tanks the Lazarus pit I mean
obviously there's more Lazarus pits around
the world that we haven't seen yet this is
the only Lazarus pit which he just took away
Merlyn season the holes so like he has no
more cards to play if he dies he ends up staying
dead but interesting I thought was really
interesting to is that when he's talking to
Thea he says there's nothing I wouldn't do
for my daughter any inner you like he threw
those leading members under the bus under
the fieldbus what if Nyssa uses that let that
type of like crazy energy to try and leave
it to against Merlyn it just because the episode
was titled restoration so I also think she's
trying to restore her birthright let me know
in the comments though what you guys think
about the resurrection scene with Sara Lance
Amis did did you like that or do you feel
like you are expecting something even bigger
I feel that they're trying to get this out
of the way now so they can actually have some
fun with Caity Lotz on screen you can have
black canary squared kicking butt like you
have a birds of prey episode this coming up
with both canaries and it and Thea so you
feel like they needed to soon it just because
they want to get to the good stuff even faster
the speaking of good stuff don't forget that
all of her tease that he has a new arrow later
in the works I mean I still call the arrow
cave you know they call for later you can
call it whatever you want but I felt like
even when Felicity was like you know machine
gunning the crap out of double down that was
kind of the impetus like okay work and destroy
this arrow cave so got to build a new one
though that was going to be the catalyst for
making the new layer but it turns out that
Oliver had one plan the whole time Felicity
just going to be the one to bankroll it and
yes this is totally Ray Palmer that's messaging
Felicity are trying to message heard that
that's what all this where Texas about it
is that when you're really small like that
Felicity wouldn't be able to hear him just
the set soundwaves don't work that way when
you really really tiny so using the computers
is the only way that he'll be able to talk
to Felicity so that you still develop that
plot line as we go along I think the strongest
actor's this week the product Felicity like
she had some of the best scenes and Thea when
she was going really really crazy like when
she's slowly killed that one big member like
she just drew the blade across his neck so
vicious the is having more fun the season
than almost any the other actors on the show
was can happen tomorrow is I'm going to catch
up with my Gotham video I still need to post
a Gotham video for this week and then I'll
try get Q&A's out for game of thrones and
arrow and the flash there was so much Star
Wars stuff in the beginning of this week I
had to rearrange a bunch of stuff so get hype
Constantine is coming soon it's going to be
awesome just in case you haven't seen it you
can click here for last night's episode of
the flash and you can click here for the Star
Wars episode 7 trailer thank you so much for
watching, everybody high five and I'll see
you guys tonight!